Президент США Дональд Трамп оголосив Євросоюзу торговельну війну.
Але що це, власне, таке?
Трамп підвищив мита на імпорт з низки країн. Зокрема з ЄС.
Приміром, 25 відсотків - на європейську сталь
та 10 відсотків - на алюміній.
На європейські автівки він також хоче підвищити мита.
Таким чином Трамп хоче допомогти американським підприємствам
наростити власне виробництво.
Європейці обурені!
У відповідь вони запровадили мита на низку американських товарів,
приміром, віскі та мотоцикли.
Ціни на цю продукцію в ЄС зростуть.
Після цього надійшли нові погрози із США -
обкласти митами ще більше європейських товарів.
Мотивація Трампа - до США має потрапляти менше конкурентних товарів з-за кордону.
Торговельні війни траплялися й раніше.
Відомий приклад з історії - Наполеон Бонапарт.
Аби послабити Англію, він заблокував у 1806 році усі британські торговельні кораблі,
які хотіли зайти до європейських портів.
Англія змогла вистояти у цій війні завдяки новим ринкам за океаном.
Трамп хоче будь-що виграти цю війну.
Але що він може для цього зробити?
Він знає: Євросоюз може втратити більше у цій війні,
адже експорт з ЄС до США перевищує імпорт.
Профіцит торговельного балансу становить 151 мільярд євро.
Саме на це він робить ставку.
Трамп може домовитися про скасування мит для окремих країн ЄС,
якщо вони у відповідь скасують свої.
Така політика може розколоти ЄС.
Тоді Трамп вийде з цього конфлікту переможцем,
позбувшись сильного конкурента.